right you've been watching this story
from the very start is there an end in
sight it's hard to see one at this point
in GI just to put this latest recall
into some context four and a half
million is more than the number of
vehicles that honda sold last fiscal
year and it's unfortunately though for
the company just the third biggest for
this year so each of the last three
months now the company has come out and
recalled more vehicles and it sells in a
year and and this is really a
significant one for the company because
it's the first under the new president
Hachiko who just took over within the
last month how has that impacted whose
role their new as it is right so I i
think it's it's fair to say that he
needs some time to get his footing to
really before we can really pass
judgment as to whether or not you know
the changes he's going to bring to the
company are going to to make any
difference but like it or not I mean his
tenure is really going to be judged on
whether or not he can kind of protect
Honda's reputation for quality because
that reputation is is that a risk as
long as the company continues to make
headlines for recalling just massive
amounts of vehicles in fairness this is
it is a supplier issue to a large extent
but it's it's certainly something that
the company wants to put behind it and
Takata isn't the only quality issues
that the company has been having as of
late Takata certainly is the the key one
though to be sure Craig and how is it
she go seen handling the Takata crisis
is he standing by this auto parts
supplier I mean what did he say about
keeping this partnership when it comes
to these components right it's it's
interesting he has been kind of pushed
out there by the company and actually
spoken with reporters twice just within
the past week and and has kind of sent
to mixed signals in terms of you know
the approach is going to take with
Takata it seems like he's not in a rush
to make a decision either way as to
whether or not the company is going to
stick with Takata he
has said that the company has no plan to
provide financial support for for Takata
but at the same time he did kind of
offer a lukewarm you know backing up of
the company yesterday when he said that
he believes the Takata the Takata
airbags that Honda is using now are safe
so at this point it's it's a little bit
unclear as to whether or not he's going
to stick by the supplier which is is
huge in terms of the safety components
that Honda uses in its vehicles it's a
major supplier to Honda